let me do it it has to be me it has to
be me
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie's so you probably
saw the Wonder Woman teasers that
dropped this morning and you're like hey
wait a minute how is Steve Trevor still
alive he definitely died on that plane
we're all pretty sure he definitely died
on that plane so it's kind of funny but
I'll explain what's going on there like
a couple things that people have been
speculating but there's also a whole
bunch of Aquaman stuff that drop
recently too they showed off like a
really long trailer so I'll add all that
stuff to the end of this video too but
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a bunch of big stuff
that's getting ready to drop first
things first
Chris Pine everybody's asking about
Steve Trevor how the hell is he still
alive
like obviously these are all 1984
pictures so everybody's in full 80's
attire he looks like he's in the middle
of the ball if you saw how I Met Your
Mother let's go to the mall today could
be playing in the background it's all
meant to be a little bit silly and
surreal at the same time
but the thing weirdly that nobody has
been talking about that I've seen so far
is the Chris Pine looks like he is not
aged a day since the 1920s remember the
events of the Wonder Woman movie were
all about World War one not World War
two so not only does he look a little
bit funny and all this 80s getup he is
not aged today
even Entertainment Weekly was wildly
speculating on the twist that was
allowing Chris Pine to be in this movie
when Steve Trevor really did die in the
past so if that wasn't clear patty
Jenkins was pretty open about his
sacrifice and how important that was to
the turn in the movie if he suddenly
showed up it would completely undercut
that so coupled with that in the fact
that he has an age today I don't think
that this is original Steve Trevor now
like Entertainment Weekly thinks that
this is his descendant who just happens
to look exactly like him in order for
that to even work at all he would have
to be Steve Trevor's great-great
grandson so there's a couple other
images and the working title of the
movie they give you a little more
information about the crazy God level
stuff that's happening in this that
makes some of these twists seem a little
more possible for now I'm just choosing
to believe that this is headspace Steve
Trevor and she's just hallucinating him
in
present-day it's just a trick of her
mind or a trick of one of the villains
until people catch footage of Chris Pine
walking around on set talking to other
characters that are not Wonder Woman
interacting with them I'm gonna choose
to believe that this is completely
headspace but like I said when you look
at the other teasers and you know about
the working title then we can talk about
some of the other options for how they
could bring him back so this is a big
image is of Diana looking at this Bank
of TVs
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs in
here so one her looking in front of this
big wall of TVs is a little bit like
splash where Dr Hanna's mermaid
character is learning about television
for the first time the wonders of modern
technology so obviously this being 1984
a lot of time has passed the world has
changed a lot they're gonna have a
little bit of fun with old timey Wonder
Woman just interacting with modern pop
culture she seems like she's been
working at the Louvre for a long time
but I'm assuming she didn't start doing
that till a little bit later so
presumably she did use the Diana Prince
persona to go around the world to have
various odd jobs but because of the way
you explained the world not really
knowing what's going on with Wonder
Woman in present day it sounds like she
did keep it on the DL a little bit like
originally the idea during Justice
League and Batman vs Superman is is that
she had sort of turned her back on man
then later after the Wonder Woman movie
came out patty Jenkins and gal gadot
said that they sort of softer rebooted
that aspect of her character so like no
she never turned her back on man so just
expect to get a little bit more of her
day to day like this is what I've been
doing this whole time during this movie
but so you have a little bit of splash
but then obviously all the images on the
banks of these TVs are meant to be
Easter eggs too so the one that
everybody noticed immediately was
Christie Brinkley from National
Lampoon's Vacation probably one of the
most iconic 80s comedy films this is
1984 so like Top Gun has not happened
yet so this fighter jet isn't Top Gun it
just meant to be an aspect of modern
warfare warfare pretty important to
Diana's character in her backstory you
see modern pop singers down at the
bottom here this upper image in the
upper right hand corner that isn't Star
Wars but Star Wars has happened so it'd
be funny to see if Wonder Woman has
actually been to see that in a theatre
most of you probably recognize the
Dallas TV show over on the left here and
then obviously some of these other
images are probably
very specific things from the 80s so if
you're around and you recognize some of
these just write them below in the
comments but for the most part this is
just meant to give you an idea for
what's going on things that happened in
real life during the 80s so they are
going to sort of tie this to real world
pop culture you kind of get a look for
her outfit here too although it is kind
of muted like she probably isn't going
to be dressing too ridiculously I don't
think they're gonna change her Wonder
Woman costume that much either like they
might alter her just a little bit but
remember it was created by Zeus so like
it's already as powerful as it's ever
going to be it's not like you're gonna
take something that was made by the most
powerful God and make it even better so
just expect a couple of color Tunes
maybe like a couple of minor highlights
change a little bit obviously because
it's the 80s they're gonna probably make
the colors pop just a little bit more
just because back during World War one
everything was covered with mud like if
you look at the coloring from the
original Wonder Woman movie there's a
lot of like really dark blues and browns
just because of the setting obviously
this being the 80s you just look at this
wall of TVs it gives you an idea for the
explosion of color here's what we get
into more cheetah Cersei magic stuff so
people have been wondering about Cersei
being in the movie because the working
title of the film is called Magic Hour
so that's a filmmaking term but it's
also like a bit of an eye wink at the
magic that they might be using in the
movie so in photography Magic Hour is
also known as Golden Hour it's this
period shortly after sunrise before
sunset during which daylight is redder
and softer compared to when the Sun is
higher in the sky so it gives off this
really glowy golden effect they kind of
did that during the original Wonder
Woman movie where she's in the sky and
it looks like everything's on fire and
everything glows like it's gold so it's
a bit of a wink at that in the
photography term but also I think the
fact that Cersei might wind up in the
film and we might have some a very
high-level magic at play because we know
that cheetah is in the film and she's
gonna be one of the main villains but
they might have a sort of misdirect with
the villains like they did in the first
Wonder Woman movie where is really Aerys
that's manipulating everything but you
don't really know him as the main
villain for most of the movie so the new
report on cheetah is that she's actually
going to start out as one
woman's a lie-in friend but then seeks
to usurp her and in the comics there's a
couple different versions of the cheetah
character the first version was actually
somebody who knew Diana was her friend
and saw her to charity in Washington DC
and then wanted to usurp her power so
she put on a cheetah costume and had
this split personality so the cheetah
that we see in Wonder Woman 2 might be a
combination of a couple different
characters but obviously we know they're
shooting scenes in Washington DC right
now Washington DC being the seat of
government I'm sure they'll have a
similar scene like they did during the
first Wonder Woman movie where she has
to rally against a bunch of really old
that don't want to do the right
thing so you have a little bit of
activism you have a little bit of
personal conflict which sounds like it's
gonna be happening with the cheetah
character but then you also have like
very high level God magic like very
powerful mythological forces in play
which sounds like you know maybe surgery
it's still a rumor right now they
haven't confirmed that she's in the
movie but Cersei is a character that
sold her soul to the dimension of Hell
and has been trying to get it back she
has the ability to change what people
look like she keeps herself young using
special potions so that you know like
obviously there's a couple crazy twists
with Chris Pine Steve Trevor character
there are ways that Cersei could be
responsible for him showing up during
the film but moving into Aquaman
territory you probably heard about all
the Aquaman footage that they showed off
at the European version of CinemaCon so
there were a bunch of theatre exhibitors
they got to see footage from all the
different studios they showed up a ton
of venom footage they showed off footage
from the Captain Marvel movie because
they're almost done filming that but
they also showed off like a genuinely
finished Aquaman trailer so people are
like when are you gonna post that people
keep saying that it's gonna be in the
next couple of days I'll believe that
when I see it but everybody's been
hyping it up people say that the
executives at Warner Brothers are really
happy with it
so it sounds like it's gonna be really
badass but obviously when that drops I
will totally do a video for it but just
leave all your Wonder Woman to theories
in the comments below how Steve Trevor
back in what's going on with magic as in
Magic Hour during the movie what'll
happen next is is I'll post new Captain
Marvel Avengers that should be up in the
next couple of hours and obviously
there's a lot of stuff dropping this
week so there might be a couple surprise
- but while you wait for everything
click here to learn about the Green
Lantern movie that they just announced
and click here for my Incredibles to
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight